[Music]
well looks like it's an image that's
synonymous with the British Monarchy a
royal family photo so on the Buckingham
Palace balcony the people across the
world are willing to camp out in the
pouring rain just to catch a glimpse of
in person this is how the actress ajua
Ando decided to describe the moment the
King Charles and queen Camila appear for
the first time following their
coronation flanked by their family on
the famous balcony
we've gone from the uh the uh the rich
diversity of the Abbey to have terribly
white balcony I'm very struck by that
well Netflix star who plays lady Danbury
in Bridgeton has now apologized for
upsetting people after a comments called
the backlash on social media but did you
have a point or was her opinion actually
the thing that was terrible
well let's discuss this now with uh
Paula Roan Adrian and Tessa Dunlop so
Paula here's my problem with this
imagine for a moment we talked about the
Tongan royal family
and I said wow the terribly
Polynesian
or terribly black
what would you have said
so I can't answer that question because
I don't know the history of the Tongan
royal family but I do know the history
of this royal family to the extent that
there are people of color in this royal
family we haven't seen for example the
descendants of Anaya her name was until
she was baptized Sarah Forbes bonetta we
don't have the descendants of for
example princess the princesses who came
from it from India why why not they're
not the kids of the senior working
Royals the only criteria for being on
the balcony is there the senior members
of the family who by the way happen to
be white when was that a crime he is not
a family of white you can shout because
you know that what I'm about to say is
going to upset you because it's right
peers Queen Victoria had a wonderful
family portrait and that family portrait
included people of color where are those
descendants why aren't they on the
balcony where is Megan
where is
her 11 million dollar mansion in
California which is gained from the
proceeds of trashing the royal family
for the last three years that's where
she is I accept at the adverb of
terribly probably wasn't what I would
choose yes disappointingly all right I
would agile actually goes to my local
church and she's a seriously Good Egg
and I think she just had a sort of
instinctive reaction that wow the people
on that balcony don't look like they
represent me I would actually move away
from the idea of very distant
descendants because that would have
looked like Curious casting just for the
sake of pleasing the press and I would
have suggested we missed a trick and I
said this on your show and I've said it
elsewhere and I've been decried by all
the Royal press pack the casting of
those honorary page boys was a massive
ball drop there was no criteria to say
for instance George Prince George being
a page boy was absolutely against
protocol to have somebody in line for
succession
so my just my I just I think I have a
list here because you came out with all
this claptrap last week I can't even
read these two cards which are all the
examples of diversity of the people in
Westminster Abbey it goes on and on and
rightly on that was the most
Multicultural service this country has
ever put on the idea wasn't it was too
white it's completely ridiculous it
appears when you're talking about the
intimate royal family which you'll
remember was rocked by now on facts of
racism don't bear with people bear with
me no they're not all family members
Tommy is not a relationship Nicholas
Barkley up there they're one of the
pictures let me ask you so let me ask
you a question you got married right in
your wedding snaps how many non-white
people are
um it was a state occasion it was not a
personal wedding and the king
that's a record so you haven't answered
my question it's detracting from the
issue it is it's simplified I simply
asked how many non-white people will be
in your wedding pictures they were all
remaining because I got married to
Romanian I wanted the Tongan to be clear
they were all to be clear right you did
you didn't go around and try and find
some people who were the immediate
family and put them in your picture to
look more diverse isn't a royal family
who would have had to look very far
peers and that's the point were you
talking about Meghan Markle why would
they watch her very far I'm so sorry you
mentioned Tonga earlier the king of
tongoro Queen is not also the monarch of
14 other Realms why not get 14 boys and
girls from those 14 other rounds that's
diverse because actually if you looked
at the congregation and who was invited
and looked at the procession of 7 000
people there were literally hundreds and
thousands actually people who were not
white in both of those right it just so
happens in the senior members of our
royal family they are white people which
last time I checked in this country is
not illegal you are allowed to be white
there was no suggestion and this is
ramping up unfairly what a joke was said
and remember
lots of wonderful things about the
coronation and she said lots of
wonderful she said about the wrong
family but she was talking about the
contrast I think it's a terribly bad
view we need to put it here and I would
go as far as to call it race-baiting
it's drawing some weird racial Dimension
to a a family we know the senior members
of the family are white we know their
kids are white what's the problem they
made they made the service and the
procession more Multicultural than
anything of its kind in the history of
the world probably and all I'm hearing
is your old terribly white it's pathetic
but peers it was about the friends they
could have cast it differently because
people how many friends did you have in
your wedding pictures none but it's not
a state occasion because your family
were all away Charles and committed you
don't practice when you preach no I'm
not talking about their personal Charles
and Camilla wedding we're talking about
a state occasion where the page boys and
the honorary Maids of Honor could have
been recruited differently it was a real
chance he could have recruited people
who were not immediate members of your
family just go off and find random
people to take some diversity it's
ridiculous they could not have been more
diverse in a diversity box this is not
about taking a diversity box and I have
to actually say about King Charles he
has said himself look this is time that
we start to look inward in terms of the
role that the royal family played in
slave trade and that's important bearing
in mind
only just recently finished paying
compensation to slave owners all right
two thousand that's another debate and
by the way we will have that debate
because that is a nonsense too the idea
that this king who couldn't be less
racist literally couldn't be if he dried
or if I paid him is that gonna have to
pay people or order the payments to
people from centuries ago the stuff that
isn't happening now to anybody connected
to that is nonsensical to me maybe I'm
the Mad one though maybe it was all
terrible or maybe actually I'm right
thank you all right